[Music]
this morning in a special holiday
edition of the dish closing out 2021
with the man who's just been named the
best restaurateur in the world that is
not praise from a critic it's his
colleagues 184 of the world's best
restaurants say no one does it better
than danielle baloo velum first made his
mark in the early 90s at his namesake
restaurant here in new york city
danielle
over the decades balut has opened new
places across the globe but this year it
was a new location in his adopted
hometown that's getting all the
attention it's been called the most
important new restaurant opening
in the history of new york city
a lot of people know oysters rockefeller
not everybody knows oysters vanderbilt
nobody knows oyster vanderbilt except if
you have been to le pavillon the
original lipavion started as a
restaurant operated by henry soulet in
the french pavilion at the 1939 world's
fair in new york by 1941 it had
transformed into a fixed location that
would become a watershed establishment
in american culinary history are you
trying to match that
no it's more a reference to
the past something very french and
something very new york from its
crossroads location in midtown manhattan
lipavion defined french cooking in the
united states for more than a quarter
century
when it shut down 50 years ago it left a
giant open table on the restaurant scene
that hasn't really been filled
until now from the window of the bar you
can see seven landmarks in new york
including the chrysler building grand
central of course perhaps no one was
better suited to reimagine lip havion
than danielle bellude the french-born
master who's been dazzling diners since
arriving stateside in the 1980s
though if you're expecting the same old
french fare here
think again is there something you want
diners to take away from this restaurant
that they may not get
at one of your other restaurants
well yeah maybe this one is the least
french
the light filled room features an
expansive indoor garden and a menu
that's 50 seafood 40 vegetables
just 10 percent meat i think it it is
contemporary in its approach
to
french fine dining and i think today
we are all transitioning into fine
casual
but how casual do we want to get versus
remain a place that
it feels a celebration and yet you can
also come very often
before we dug into balud's christmas
feast a tantalizing sample a tribute to
the man who not only championed grand
central station
but for whom the building we're in was
named what is the oyster vanderbilt the
oyster vanderbilt it's a baked oyster so
the oyster have been lightly baked in
the oven and then what we do
we take part of the oysters to make a
shower
and i have some leeks so we are putting
some leeks on the bottom of the shell
you've always been big on oysters at
holiday meals
yes why
it's a winter shellfish in the old days
they used to say that
any months in our from september to
april you could eat shellfish i'm
getting very hungry
and then over the oysters goes
across
and this crust
is made of
seaweed
and
as a nut butter
and herbs
and that goes into the salamander so you
can bake that in the oven otherwise
and uh we're gonna wait two minutes and
have an oyster vanderbilt okay
voila can we eat yeah we are ready
you can take a spoon
and you try to be careful because the
shower inside is a little bit liquid so
you go underneath
and you pick up your stir like this
oh wow
and of course
we'll scrap the shell
and get all these delicious
crust and oyster
fantastic
well done i'm gonna have another one i
will too
oysters vanderbilt was one of the dishes
balud's team prepared for a sumptuous
holiday spread that included just to
start
a winter salad with black truffles and
celery roots
spinach with grapes and pickled jalapeno
and a roasted beet salad coated with
sesames
the seeds
they make it oh completely they make the
whole thing because we cut the slice of
beet with the sesame and then we roasted
on the sesame and let it toast and that
i think really give
the dish some particular flavor have a
little bit of lobster i'm going to the
lobster salad included gem lettuce herbs
and radish there was grilled avocado
with acorn berry and a green goddess
dressing
plus tuna tartare with fennel and olive
saka
all leading up to the pies de resistance
a roast chicken with truffles tucked
under the skin
served with potatoes and winter
vegetables how do you get the truffles
just underneath the skin
well you
have to pass your finger between the
skin and
the flesh of the chicken along the
breast and the legs and then you have to
slide in the slice of truffle underneath
for dessert baloo took things over the
top
a spider-like hazelnut cake
black forest cake his take on apple pie
topped with a curved thin puff pastry
and the ghetto di voyage
pound cake filled with almonds and
candied fruits
in the 1700 in france they were
traveling with
their own
cakes and things and they created a gato
di voyage which was a cake that could
last couple of days without
refrigerating le pavion's opening here
was momentous happening on the very day
new york city began accepting diners
again at full capacity how tough for you
have the last two years been
i mean it has been the toughest year we
ever
came across
we had to furlough
800 people
a year and a half ago but most important
was to bring back staff and
we did that gradually and i think today
we have about 550 employees back and i
have few more restaurants to open so
it's good
people have been coming here to make up
for lost
actually and we see it every day people
want to indulge in good wine
great food
people want to have fun
fun
food
wine
and health
all things to be grateful for as we
celebrate this second holiday season
amid these most unusual times for me the
holiday is also
a nice cocktail or champagne
[Laughter]
let's get our hands full here i know
totally but i'd go for the champagne
happy holidays cheers cheers happy
holidays